Jackson Diagnostics is like the waiting
room from hell
while inmates go through a battery of
tests designed to classify their
security levels they have few privileges
and even fewer pleasures but each week
there's at least one thing to look
forward to at the heart of Jackson's
life is the store this is that our light
of these inmates day store day this is
like Christmas to them this is where
they go and restart
store items are bought with money sent
from families or friends outside the
prison but in here these items become
more than just care packages each
represents a value each can be traded
sold and gambled each item is in essence
money it is money and it's that way of
actually trading bargaining they don't
have anything yes that might be his
cigarette mug store a seemingly
innocuous dispensary of honey buns in
candy has a darker side it drives a
black market economy the system can
barely keep on top of when the inmates
call the hustle maxwell house supreme
to deal an extra Arabica beans inside
see we can't buy this coffee off the
store it's contraband this is what we
call it WIC right here it's a long piece
of toilet paper twisted up that keeps a
flame on the end for a lot of amount of
time and so you make another one
[Music]
everybody's got a hustle in here some
people keep the week's burn and some
people sell cigarettes like us some
people sell coffee like us as well we
just try to make as much money as we can
that way we can be as comfortable as
possible inside of this place a pack of
cigarettes here go for 25 items take 25
20 buttons those are a big thing
chengyang cigarettes this is the chain
gang crap bugle cigarettes
from transporting contraband to doing
laundry drawing tattoos even making
greeting cards these are jobs as good as
they come in prison each is paid in
store